[Music]
[Applause]
figures just released by the FTTH
council show an impressive 20 percent
growth in fiber deployment across Europe
in the last year alone giving her
reaction is our director general Percy
abet Vettori as you but that's gonna be
great news 20% growth yes indeed Thank
You Bryan it is very good news that
fiber availability in adoption is
growing consistently year on the year
across Europe yet we still have a lot to
do so we're not there yet where we would
like to be which is ubiquitous fiber
based connectivity for every European
citizen and business I think however as
you said the news are encouraging and I
would just like to highlight our host
country Spain where I think that both
the political commitment the regulatory
regime and also the very strong
contribution of the operators have
resulted in an enormous
the high flavor coverage and also
digitalization of the entire country yes
and also in the last few minutes you've
announced the results of a
socio-economic survey showing the
effects of FTTH on the population what
for you have been some of the highlights
of those findings this has been indeed a
very interesting survey so we have
actually asked over 1,000 Swedish
customers consumers of their fiber
experience and the results are also
extremely interesting there so one of
the findings of the report was that
actually the main reasons why end-users
or choosing fiber are because of high
speeds so it's really much higher speeds
than any other infrastructure can
provide and secondly actually consumers
find that it is better value for money
the second finding which which i think
is so quite interesting is that fiber
end users are generally much happier
with the quality of service the
performance of the network the
connectivity that they are receiving
then of the consumers of any other
technology so fiber actually rocks when
it comes to the end-user experience
and thirdly those consumer is in Sweden
who are not yet connected to fiber
almost all of them one
to have fiber so 94% of those who are
not yet on a fiber connection would
happily consider it should it become
available in their area are talking
about things rocking this event again
has been very busy very well attended
what for you have been some of the
highlights well I think the theme of the
conference has been very important to us
because we think that the theme
connecting Technology Policy and the
world of finance are some of the key
ingredients actually to get ubiquitous
fiber coverage across here we have to
get technology policy and the investment
element right in order to have massive
flavor investments and deployment across
Europe as well as of course fibre
adoption by end-users and we had the
CEOs of all the major operators of Spain
telling us about the Spanish success
story and the best practices that I
think we could all learn from but those
are very interestingly I have just
moderated the investor panel and there
have been some very interesting
perspectives shared by
the analyst community as well as the
investing operators and fiber networks
in one of these themes that that has
come out actually as several of the
discussions was that copper is more
important for the fiber investment case
then we would actually think or than we
discuss it today so actually I think
that one of the key takeaways of the
conference and the discussions that have
taken place here is that we need to have
a more thorough in open European level
dialogue about the migration process
from copper to fiber and ultimately
about decommissioning the old copper
networks very interesting thank you for
sharing your time with us and
congratulations again on the on the new
figures thank you very much Brian
[Music]
you